what was that one moment Tom became
Spider-Man Milani was casted for Miss
Marvel just like that every MCU Hero has
a making up story and you'll be
surprised at just how different they all
are it took a long time to find the new
MCU Spidey even though Tom Holland was
an obvious choice the whole process took
approximately seven months in multiple
rounds of auditions add that onto a
whole lot of gymnastics training and the
Trampoline Jumping that Tom just
couldn't resist doing he worked hard to
get the role for sure but you know when
he really became a superhero Marvel
president Kevin feige explained what
that moment was it's lifting the rubble
and it has stuck with me my whole life
and from the moment I joined Marvel
Studios I was like we should do that in
the movies did Ayman villani really just
wake up one day and become Miss Marvel
not exactly but thanks to her aunt she's
submitted to a quite sketchy casting
call for the title role on WhatsApp is
that not a scam I mean it looks yeah and
keep in mind she's fresh out of high
school at this point and she's a huge
fan of Miss Marvel so any opportunity is
a good one and then the next day I get a
call they're like do you have a lawyer
we want to fly to LA and I was like I
have a math test but can we like we'll
figure this out okay she even dressed up
as the superhero long before ever
playing her in the MCU so this was just
a long time in the making comedy star
Paul Rudd was not prepared for what it
took to become a superhero having to
really push himself to work out every
day was rather different from his comedy
movie repertoire he was enormously
shocked when Marvel execs approached him
for the role but something switched and
he was now Scotland's Ant-Man he fit
right in the superhero Persona saying I
certainly exercised and trained little
carbs no cookies no alcohol my suit was
real I'm a little biased but I think
it's the best looking suit
Florence Pugh had the director and
producers on her side for the role of
Elena in Black Widow the producers over
at Marvel were shocked to know director
shortland through Pugh at the top of the
list because they found her to be the
best as well first time the two sides
actually agreed on something for real
The Producers loved her fighting side
from her role in fighting with my family
and shortland was obsessed with her
performance in Lady Macbeth her
reputation quite literally made her a
hero Evangeline Lily was completely on
board when Edgar Wright approached her
and told her she'd be working alongside
Paul Rudd and Ant-Man her becoming an
MCU hero wasn't so easy as ruds however
she actually almost dropped out due to
Wright's departure from the film it
wasn't really even made apparent as to
when she'd even donned her costume but
she was sure ready to surprise her fans
on Instagram when the time came ask and
you shall receive just as simulu did to
become Shang Chi he was already
respected in the film Community but it
was going to take a whole lot more him
to get a shot at the hero role he took
it upon himself to convince Marvel on
Twitter for the role saying okay at
Marvel are we gonna talk or what after a
brief phone call Liu returned Victorious
thanks for getting back to me can you
imagine being the first and only choice
to play a superhero like Anthony Mackey
well he did kind of initiate the option
to begin with having his team pitch his
superhero qualities to the MCU the first
he was going up for was the Mandarin in
Iron Man 3. eventually going to Ben
Kingsley who knocked it out of the park
but he must have had a great Entourage
because it wasn't long after that that
they just gave him the role of Falcon in
Captain America Winter Soldier Sochi
Gomez went through a long and arduous
process for the role of America a
process that took several auditions over
the course of months being that
Multiverse of Madness is an important
step in the mcu's timeline casting had
to make sure they found the perfect
Supergirl when Gomez finally made it to
a test screening with Benedict
Cumberbatch she almost became so
Starstruck I was trying to like
literally play cool I was like don't try
and like don't be a fan right now the
rest involved a whole lot of kickbox
training and stunt rehearsals easy right
when the iconic Chadwick Boseman passed
away the future of black panther was
uncertain it was always made apparent
that Leticia Wright would team up as an
additional black panther later on but
now it was time for her to Don the suit
she worked for months preparing for
stunts and working out more than ever
before those are quite big shoes to fill
and she did so in her own unique way the
MCU could not hold on to Oscar Isaac for
Moon Knight he was eager to film season
one but had his contract end at that
Oscar wasn't sure how fans would receive
it and just did not want to over commit
to something that wouldn't be successful
he stated we all agreed that this show
is what we are going to focus on this is
the story and if there's any kind of
future I think it just depends on if
people like it if people want to see
more and if we find a story that's worth
telling how come there's like a million
portals to jump through in the MCU for
some actors but for others it's just a
sketchy WhatsApp flyer do you think you
have what it takes to become the next
MCU superhero let us know in the
comments
[Music]